那我们正式开始我们今天的第二个部分嘛然后当然我觉得肯定是东哥做做不牛逼的事情他一定是他也是一个牛逼的人所以我们在但是大家肯定很关心嘛因为其实对于东哥来说肯定也不是说一出来可能就是APM团队的客户当负责人或者一出来可能就在做一些非常厉害的事情那他也是从一个新手慢慢的走过来的那我们直播间同学会很好奇啊那东哥在整个过程中经历了哪些成长阶段的
东哥可以大家介绍一下你可能需要先解一下经营好的OK看我自己的一个成长经历来说大概我个人认为可以分为三个阶段吧第一个阶段可能就是刚毕业或者说毕业两年之内我觉得在这个阶段我们是一个比较初阶甚至是一个比较菜鸟的一个同学对吧毕竟是新手刚进入这个行业那在这个阶段我们
一个角色或者定位更多的像一个执行者那么可能在这个阶段我们更多的时候是作为一个执行者找的一个角色然后相当于可能我们在团队中有一些team leader或者说你的mental或者架构师来分配给你一些工作对吧可能这个时候你没有一些太多主动选择的机会那你需要做的就是说我们需要将这些分配过来的一些任务我们需要做的又快又滑吧
说实话在这个阶段我个人认为做一个执行者我们需要做的最重要的就是说去意思说你完成东西交付交付的代码的一个质量另外就是效率然后一次同时你要去去注重自己的个人一个技术积累一些成长在这个阶段你一定会遇到一些比如说难题对吧比如说一些代码怎么去设计然后一些bug怎么去修复在这个过程中你一定要去积累更多的一个经验有点像去打怪升级吧
在这个阶段相当于我认为是你个人的成长曲线也是最快的ok 那经历这个阶段之后那有可能假如说你在一些比如说同年年段的一些同学或者说一些同一阶段入职的一些同学中你做的比较出色对吧可能你把leader交付你的任务做得既快又好交付的质量很高然后同时得到一些合作方的一些配合同学的认可之后呢有可能成长为一个方向的一个owner
那么做一个方向O你应该具备什么样的素质呢首先就是我作为我们做技术嘛首先你肯定要有比较过硬的一个专业能力首先你肯定要做好一些比如说一些复杂的一些技术方案的设计那在过程中可能会遇到一些技术难题一定要有一些这种解决一些技术难题有一个攻坚克难的一个能力然后与此同时你还可以去做一些
中短期的一个规划比如说我们做在这个方向我们做一些双月或者说半年内的一个规划然后第二点我认为方向O相比于直线同学一个非常显著的差异就是说你必须有更强的一个指动性然后相比于
一个执行者而言那做一个方向用的你需要更多的去提高自己的主动性对吧你需要去更主动的去发现当前业务或是技术上一些潜在的一些问题然后你能够独当一面的作为这个方向的一个接口人对吧然后你能够主动的去发起发起一些技术优化点发起一些技术项目并且有能力去推动它去完整的落地
然后作为方向lead我更认为也是需要去对团队的一些同学的成长去需要参与和负责然后你有能力去带领团队的一些初阶的同学去完成一个整体的一个项目对吧然后带领大家去共同的成长这是方向Owner的一个阶段那么过了这个阶段假如说你在方向Owner这个阶段又做的比较好比较出色比较受lead的认可那么可能后面你会成长为一个团队管理者
OK 那么团队管理者我们的能力要求肯定会会更多了那么首先可能你做一个团队团队管理者你需要有更好的一个技术事业对吧你能够对当前的一个业务领域有一个自己更深刻更全面的一个认认识和理解然后你对于各种场景下不同的一个技术方案他们各自的优劣是对吧你要心中有数然后要要有一个大概的一个理解
然后你还能够去做一些更中程期的一些技术规划比如说半年甚至一年内的这样一个技术规划并且把它做一些合理的拆解和分配对然后第二点就是说你作为TMD的需要有一些技术判断力然后你能够什么是技术判断力呢个人我就说你能够识别当前的一个技术场景当前你们的业务发展阶段我们遇到了一些平静或者一些关键问题到底是什么那么
虽然比如说可能在某个领域某个某个方面我们遇到一些问题呢可能在业界有一些不同的一些开源解决方案那么我们到底哪个方案是最贴合你当前的业务场景对吧是最适合你当前这个业务发展阶段你需要做出一些比较科学比较合理的一些技术决策这就是所谓的技术判断理然后还有一点就是说你作为team leader或者说团队管理者一定是
需要对团队的团队同学对整体去负责对吧你不再是一个IC不再是一个单打独斗的一个同学那么做一个团队管理的话你需要去识别出当前同学甚至或者说你带着同学的对吧你的一些能力模型以及他们的性格特点然后需要将合适的人放在合适的事情上就尽量做到这个人与事就尽量的去做一个
更高的一个匹配然后发挥出大家更高的一个战斗力对吧因为作为团队管理者嘛你不仅仅说你自己优秀你自己的能力很强那么你的团队的战斗力团队的能力就很强这本身不是一个必定是话一个等号那作为听力的可能需要更多的去关注团队整体同学的一个整体的战斗力和整体大家的一个成长OK反正我总结下来就是大概是这三个阶段嘛OK
好的然后东哥这三个阶段的话其实更多的是对于我们这些已经工作同学会比较有帮助嘛那其实因为我们直播间线也有很多高校的同学他们其实现在还是在校园阶段嘛那其实比如说东哥的话他肯定也是从校园阶段成长过来的那其实在校园阶段东哥就你想想以前在校园时期的话你觉得哪些东西对你是比较重要的嗯我看其实回一下来我我个人认为对我最重要的几个点
首先我觉得第一个点可能就是你个人的兴趣这个东西我觉得有可能大家在高考在报田志愿报专业的时候有可能你最终去的那个专业对吧可能并不是你真正想去的专业也有可能你对这个专业的理解你实际去接触它去学了之后你发现和你自己当时的认知是完全不一样的对吧那么可能我认为就是大家在本科在大学或者是研究生阶段
一定要找到你自己的一个兴趣就是你想做什么对吧那有可能比如说我我本科读的是通信工程那可能我因为通信工程算是计算机相关的一个专业吧那在大三达二的时候我去接受到编程这个事情那可能也会参加到一些活动比如说一些软件大赛等等在这个过程中我会发现我对编程对计算机这个领域的兴趣会更浓厚一些所以说也是从这个阶段开始就是
算是一个萌芽吧然后一直走到今天这个阶段所以说我觉得大家在校园这个阶段一定要去找到自己的一个兴趣因为兴趣是最好的老师我觉得相信大家都应该能有体会然后第二个点就是说我觉得大家在大学阶段一定要有自己一个名称的目标什么意思呢就可能你要去设想一下毕业之后你到底想做什么有可能你想出国有可能你想考研有可能你想比如说
做技术就直接工作那技术也有很多细分的领域你想做前端做后端做客户端做算法对吧可能每一个方向每一个目标它都有不同的一个实现的一个路径对吧你只有目标明确了之后你才能够去更好地去直到你日常的一个行动对吧然后你才不会感到迷茫然后从结果倒推
比如说我假如说几年之后我想进入一个外企或者说我想拿到一个国外一个很好学校的office那么今天我今天应该做什么这个事情是可以从结果去倒退的话你目标明确了那你自然而然你努力的方向就非常明确那你做事情也会更加有动力最终这个目标也会更容易达成ok然后第三点就是个人认为就是一个视野吧
那么刚才提到了假如说你确立了一个目标之后有可能我不知道今天的同学有没有在一些二三线城市有可能你不在一个非常大的城市可能你信息获取的渠道并没有别人那么方便但是其实像我毕业已经是本科毕业已经十年前的事情了但是我想在今天已经这个情况会有所不同了就什么意思呢就说今天互联网高度发达就是大家获取信息的渠道其实是越来越方便了
就是剛才提到的無論你想做哪一個方向比如說你想去出國你想去做技術你想去做算法你確立了你的目標之後就是一定要去打開你的視野你需要了解到在這個方向在這個領域你需要接觸到更多視角的一些信息的輸入你需要跟更多的一些前輩去交流對吧你需要獲得更多的一些信息輸入讓這樣才能輔助你去做出一些更準確的一些判斷
避免你少走一些弯路举个例子比如说你想出国对吧那么你申请哪个国家的哪个学校对吧这其中就是有很多的门道那假如说你想做技术比如说你想做后端那么可能10年前购语员刚刚刚刚发明他是默默无闻的但是这10年间购语员已经已经占据了很多后端的一些一些应用和场景对吧那么你想做前端
可能最近越来越多的一些研发的胖价比如VOE Reactor包括最近新出的一些框架你是不是应该去了解一些你这个方向一些前沿的一些趋势和动态就一定要避免呃避免呆在自己的一个自我认知的一个局限里一定要把事业打开去接受更多的信息输入对然后做一些更更更合理的一些判断对这是我想跟可能现在在学校在学校的一些同学分享吧
OK所以总的来说像东哥讲这个其实就是三个点嘛第一个就是兴趣第二是目标第三个是视野那我理解其实这三点之间应该是有一定关系的比如说你的兴趣可能会决定你会定一个如果你根据你的兴趣定一个目标可能你会更容易去达成这个目标而对于视野来说如果你有更好的视野的话那你做的这个目标可能会更科学更好一点我是不可以这么理解这三点之间其实还是有一些
辅助關係的對對對是有遞進的所以我也是安排這個順序對是有遞進的ok然後希望這個問希望東哥這個回答對高校同學能有一些幫助那可以看出來就是東哥其實在整個過程一直是在成長的對他是一個不管是在校園時期還是說在這個整個職業審期職業時期那我們先想問一下就是比如說在東哥你這個成長過程中對你幫助最大的三個點是什麼嗯嗯ok
总结下来我认为对我个人成长帮助最大的三个点可能第一个我还是会选择兴趣因为刚才提到我可以分享一下我做客户端研发的一个新路立场就是刚才也提到了就是我在本科在大二大三的阶段开始对编程感兴趣但是至于具体为什么选择了客户端研发这个方向其实就在我毕业的时候是一二年时间前在那个阶段
移动端研发其实是刚兴起然后当时是一个非常火热的一个状态当时的我看到一些信息输入吧就是在一些编程语言排行榜上就是Objective-C这种编程语言是仅次于C应该仅次于C吧去排在第二名然后我就对英文C大家本来都随便都学过嘛这个太经典了那Objective-C可能对它比较感兴趣呢我就好奇去搜了一下哦原来是这个
蘋果生態的一門開發語言然後當時又對蘋果的一些工業設計對MacBook非常感興趣所以就就涉足了這樣一個道路就是說最初我做技術包括做iOS開發其實都是源於自己的興趣就是真的我對這個東西是非常感興趣的而且所以說我自己願意去投入一些很多的熱情包括一些額外的一些時間和精力去在這個事情在這個方向上那麼假如說你對一個
事情没有兴趣你只是把它当成一个谋生的手段那么你很难在这个这份工作在这个事情上去投入一些付出一些额外的一些经历那么你既然没有付出一些额外的经历和热情那么你也很难获得一些额外的回报所以这是我认为兴趣的重要性其次就是选择吧可能这个也是老生常谈的一个问题可能选择大于努力这个这句话大家已经
听到耳朵都摸出剪子了那么我想分享一下我个人的一个经历吧可能对我来说我认为几次比较重要的选择然后第一次选择是我在刚毕业一年的时候面临一个换工作的选择然后背景是什么呢背景是我在商家公司名漏就不说了在商家公司可能有一些架构调整然后相当于我是被动的从A业务调整了调整到了B业务但是对B业务这个事情这个方向
我整体不是非常的认可所以说在这个架构的调整之后我很快就想而且当时做了一些事情我感觉有点无聊然后对我的成长我觉得是一个比较大的障碍所以当时我个人的想法就是我一定要去一个成长快的一个地方然后也当时对这个调整有一些失望所以就可能在
在调整之后的不久的时间内就开始投简历然后开始去面试对然后最终选择了自己然后因为当时在我在我的印象中自己是一个发展比较快的一个创业公司因为当时一终年自己的规模没有那么大那么我认为创业公司你一定说对人的这种综合能力对你的技术水平要求的会更高那么在这样一种快速发展的环境中你的个人的成长也会有一个非常大的进步然后甚至当时我在上一家公司其实已经获得了一个精神的机会
当时在我走的时候HR会挽留我说我看你这边晋升达边已经通过了为什么还是选择离开呢对当时我的回答就是第一我可能对现在这个环境有一点点失望第二就是我想去一个对我个人成长来说发展更加派出的一个地方对所以这个点我也可以分享一下我猎头朋友的一个话他他说这句话是这么说的是永远不要让薪资成为你留下或者离开的唯一理由
我觉得这句话放在我这个经历中是一个比较好的一个解读就是当时我在商家公司其实已经获得竞产机会对吧刚才已经提到了那么竞产你一定会有一个加薪你的薪资其实一定会有一个提升的那对你来说其实是比较好的一个机会但是对我个人而言当时我看重的并不是特别是直接发展出气我建议大家不要太多的关注一个薪资上面一个东西不要说单纯的认为哪里给的钱多我就去拿
或者这里给的钱少我就一定要走对 还是要更更加注重自己的一个成长的一个速度OK 另外一个选择就是我在字节这边可能17年的时候面临一个选择到底是继续做业务还是做一个基础架构的一个方向然后当时我个人的兴趣会认为基础架构它的无论是在技术的广度还是深度的要求对人的要求都会更高那么在这个方向上我个人可能会会获得一些
更有深度的一些成长然后同时我对这些底层的一些技术技术也会更感兴趣会觉得这些事情这些技术可能它的一个生命力会更持久对然后所以而且做技术中台你可能你后面的一个杠杆的一个作用会更好所以后面就选择了去做技术技术方向这是对我来说两个比较关键的一个选择然后我没办法说
这两个选择一定是100%或者说非常完美但是我想表达的是我每个选择其实都是听从了自己内心的意见就大家在做选择的时候谁也没有办法去预见未来的发展呢你需要做的就是听从你内心的意见不要跟你的一个兴趣不要跟你的一个目标去相违背对 就听从内心的选择吧然后我觉得是是是是好是坏是正确是错误那交给时间去去回答
然后再一个点就是你一定要主动给自己去找一些挑战不要去一直满足于做你很熟悉很熟练或者很擅长的一些事情也不要觉得我在我自己已经在当前的这个团队在当前的公司我已经很优秀很厉害了那你一定要像更更优秀的一些人才去看齐你可以像你的加一加二对吧像一些更高层的一些leader去看齐跟他们去学习然后像业界的一些
更优秀更前沿的一些同学甚至像一些你这个方向这个领域国际上的一些很很很优秀的一些大牛去学习就永远不要满足说我今天我认我已经很厉害了我就不思进去了我就开始躺平了对我觉得大家一定要去主动给自己去寻找一些挑战永远不要满足于你困在自己的一个舒适圈里就是我想说的三个最最重要的一些点吧
好的可以看出来就是东哥确实费怎么说呢就是有非常有强烈的这个成长的欲望的一个人然后其实刚才说这三个点嘛就是还是兴趣然后选择和和视野对吧我理解是这三个点然后其实我觉得选择固然中有一个点道觉得我是觉得比较有意思的就第一个点第一个点是就这个点里面是怎么就比如说东哥想让他去离开了这个事情嘛
他可能更多的还是遵循了内心的想法并没有说我可能看中钱这个问题这个点其实我非常赞同因为我经常因为我也工作10年了嘛然后也有一些经验也做管理呃我可能也会跟很多我的也有很多也有很多比如说这种年轻年轻的同学吧会问我这个问题就关于钱但我我永远是这么讲的就是钱肯定是非常重要的就我们
工作嘛就是为了赚钱这个反正不丢人说赚钱这些不丢人但是呢确实是钱是不能成为唯一的你想要的一个东西而且钱肯定不是最重要的那个东西你真正重要的是你自己想要成为一个什么样的人所以我觉得这个对对来说我觉得对于一些新手啊以及对于这些高校同学来说应该都还是很有帮助的甚至我觉得对于所有工作同学来说应该都是很有帮助的其实包括我接触的一些业界的前辈他们其实到了一定阶段可能有的财务自由了
有的技术已经到了应进级了但是你会发现他们还是在根据自己内心的一些想法去做事情他们可能也没有那么去看中那些钱的东西OK 那我们再看一下另外一个点吧因为像东哥现在也是负责APM团的负责人嘛APM的话像我们讲的i performance management这个东西确实是移动端非常深的一个领域了那这个领域一定也会有很多专家那对于专家这个方向
比如说像东哥你觉得应该审完那个成长路径会比较健康一点的这个问题我们聚焦在一个技术领域的专家或者说我们认为一个加购师的这样一个角色我认为就是专家方向的一个成长路径首先我觉得最重要的一点就是你个人一定是专业能力要一定要过硬就是可能你自己的一个技术的深度广度可能要在团队里要有一个比较突出的一个
这样一个能力然后你有能力去解决我们当前业务遇到了一些难题无论是我们的架构设计还是我们在性能或者稳定性方面遇到了一些瓶颈还是有一些突发的一些紧急的问题或者是一些长久以来的疑难问题我觉得作为技术专家就是说每当我们遇到难题的时候第一时间想到那个人他就应该是我们团队最权威的技术专家
如果你做到这一点的话那么认为你应该是一个非常资深的一个人家其次我觉得作为一个人家而言你还是也得有一些不错的一些技术视野就是你得比如说我们对于当前的业务发展我们对于当前的一个架构设计我们对于性能优化你得有一些对他的一个各个技术方向的一个长期的眼睛你应该得有一些自己的一些思路和看法
然后并且能够带领一些同学去把你的一些想法逐步的去落地OK然后我觉得技术专家虽然不是管理但是也需要去带领团队同学一起去做事情对可能你得需要带领团队一些中级中阶出阶的一些同学去有能力去规划并且完成落地一些可能比较有复杂度的一些就是项目可能一些底层的一些就是成构对吧或者一些
大的架构调整应该带领大家去带领一些同学然后把这些事情做成了同时然后也能够带领大家去共同的成长对我认为专家就专家的一个成长路径大概是这样就是如果说选一就最重要的话就是说当这个团队遇到一些技术难题大家第一时间想到你那你就是一个很很合格的一个技术人家
嗯这句话很经典确实是如果你成为这个团队不可或缺的那你肯定是个专家啊对然后因为我们上一场我不知道他还记不记得直播间有没有之前看过的比如说卡比讲价过那一场其实大概都讲到就是技术能力就专业知识还是第一位的对吧可能有你们今天会讲价格和专家可能是两个不同的方向但是可能前提是你必须都要具备非常好的专业基础然后可能会在两个角色不同角色上面有一些自己的不同侧中点的选择的
OK那第二个就是因为你一直在成长吗肯定是要做学习的有没有什么比较好的一个学习资料可以推荐呢这个我就主要讲iOS领域啊因为比如说你说安卓呀或者其他技术方向啊这这个我我没有太多的设立函我只能说针对iOS这个领域那么首先对于刚入行的同学我可能会推荐几本书比如说这个一个很经典的一本书就是一个日本人写的那个
iOS与Mac与OSX多线常常内容管理这本书它有一些底层原理以及一些比喻非常形象有可能这本书它有一些内容可能是过时的或者是偏成就的但是它的内容的深度以及它的结构我认为还是比较不错的另外一个点就是推荐大家去读一下 Effective系列可能在比如说 Effective Object C2.0 Effective C++可能很多的编程语言都会有这样一本书
那我觉得这样一本书可以去养成大家一个良好的一个编程习惯那么可能在写一些代码的时候你就会会能留意到在这个场景下我可能更适合选择什么样的一个设定模式或者说怎么样去编写我的代码对吧可能有一些什么样的潜在的风险你应该去留意什么会养成一个你的一个风险良好的一个习惯吧或者说一些预防风险一些意识对再一个就是
一个台湾同胞写的这个kakeboxls入门教授这个这个内容比较比较有趣啊灰显它其中有很多比喻而且这个台湾那边很多的教法跟我们是有些不一样的我觉得读这本书的时候你也可以有一个另外的乐趣比如说他们把程序叫成城市然后网络叫网路然后这个内存泄漏叫记忆体漏水对我觉得还是挺有意思的然后它其中的一些
比喻或者描述我觉得还是对这真挺有意思的鼓励大家去看一下然后再说到技术深度的话就是偏向一些入门或者新手的一些一些书籍如果是偏向技术深度的话假如说你现在做一些基础技术方向那么推荐这个那么大后书就是OIS internum可能我们主要是专注在第一次就说用户态这一本然后
除此之外我推荐大家去读一本也是一本集团级领域比较经典的书叫成学员的自我修养 链接装载与库那么可能它其中的一些例子是用Windows以及Linux去做例子但是我觉得跟Mac或者是IOS的可成文件它有很多的类似的地方也会给大家很多的启发那可能你做月底仓你会发现各个平台各个领域它其实是相通的
比如说你了解了Linux底层的一些编译链接的一些原理呢一知道这个IOS端的话其实是完全的非常自然的这些你的认识你的理解你的这些经验都是可以去歉意的ok然后除此之外的话我个人看的最多的还是一些技术公众号的文章比如说我们字节的比如说字节的端技术架构然后字节整个的这个技术公众号还有这个
淘宝微信等等然后这些技术公众号会不定时的去推送一些很有质量的一些技术文章我从其中其实收获非常多的然后除此之外大家也可以去关注我们的一些周报比如说老司机就周报把墨鱼周报它会把一些可能一些前沿一些比较深度的一些文章做一些会总
也是一个很不错的形式然后出此之外大家也可以关注一些业界的一些会议比如说这个gmtcqcon AXAMENT就刚才那个移动也提到在大概在8月份我们团队会有两个同学会做一些公开的分享然后出此之外大家也可以去获取一些碎片化的一些消息比如说在微博上在一些有质量的一个微信的基础权利可能这些信息比较碎片化但我个人认为不要求大家在这个
一些聊天里把每一个技术点都吃得非常透那可能你当别人一些提到一些新点一些新知识的时候你需要对他有一个大概的理解有一个大概的一个概念那么假设某一天你遇到他的话你知道我这个东西可能别之前别人提过他分享过一些资料那么回过头来我是不是能找到这样一些学习资料对吧一些一些一些东西辅助你去深入和掌握对就是我大概想到想到几个点
OK,我觉得东哥推荐了很多资料大家不一定记得住然后稍后我们应该会发整个总结发总结的时候我们会把这些书籍都列在我们总结推微信推文的最后大家放心那我们再看一下因为现在东哥一代团队了嘛比如说你是比较看重团队成员的哪一块的素质呢其实这个问题啊我觉得可以这样就是假如说我在面试一个人的时候我愿不愿意给他发奥法我们可以简单的可以
等同意这个问题直播间应该有很多同学对你们团队是感兴趣的从我招人的标准来看那我可能个人最注重的还是说我们在计算机这个方向上的一个专业的一个基础就包括我们对你的这个基础知识掌握的是不是足够扎实然后对于一些计算机的一些底层的比如说操作系统组成原理比如说这个计算机网络
比如说内存管理比如说算法与数据结构等等这些底层的基础掌握是不是足够扎实然后除此之外我也会看你当前在一些垂直的技术领域上的你的深度比如说我们在LS领域你对RoundTime,Roundloop,MicroDYLD这些底层的一些基础的一些库或者一些底层的一些特性一些原理是不是有一些了解
认识以及一些应用对当然有些同学可能说我在我公司可能完全没有机会去去做APM这样的业务接触到一些底层的一些原理或者知识那么我怎么有机会去去转到这样一些底层的方向呢那从我个人来看假如说OK你在之前没有任何这样一些底层的一些经验或者是太多的一个经验那么我们在做上层的业务比如说我们做一些
做UI做交互那么我期望我们这些同学在排版 绘制一些UI有余的底层面理上有过一些深入的理解这样的话也算是一些工作当中的亮点嘛然后其次我们也看重这个同学的一个综合的能力比如说你是不是比较好沟通比较好协作你是不是能够主动的去牵头并且推进一些
一些事情对吧一些技术项目然后同时我们也期望你在过往的经历中你自认为有一些比较能拿得出手的一些你的代表作对吧你自认为比较比较比较骄傲你比较认可一些事情一些项目我也很乐意听到大家去去在面试的时候去跟我分享一些这样一些故事一些经历OK大概是这几点好的挑重点啊就直播间对东哥团队感兴趣的一定要
一定要記住現在你們現在應該還是有這樣的招人的計劃嗎目前是有招人計劃團隊其實也比較缺人但是現在相對來說比較缺一些高階的感覺可能對一些工作年輕對能力可能要求會稍微高一些然後其次實習生同學也會比較缺如果今天在聽了有高校同學的話也歡迎通過各種渠道聯繫到我然後去聊一聊看一看
OK今天最有效的渠道就是直播间右下角的二位马这是最有效的渠道进群就可以直接联系到东哥好吧